Russian airstrikes on Herson city were
cause for renewed alarm in a region
recovering from last week's Deluge
caused by the breach of kakovka dam
residents on the ukrainian-controlled
West Bank of the danipro river are
accustomed to artillery attacks from the
Russian occupied East not the sheer
destruction delivered by missiles fired
from the air
this is the first time they've hit the
city center by rockets and it's scary
because we lived under occupation for
such a long time and people are adapting
to Terrible Things rather than good
things as you see they're shelling us
regularly Russian missile attacks have
maintained a consistent Pace elsewhere
with the Central City of krivir targeted
again just two days after an apartment
building was struck killing 12 people
this time it was industrial warehouses
an attempt Ukraine's military said to
destroy what it called logistical
support
the kakovka dam flood waters signaled
dangers elsewhere the dam had supplied
water to a reservoir used to cool the
six reactors of the zaporizia nuclear
plant this was the head of the
international atomic energy agency
Rafael Grossi leading his team in an
on-site inspection all wearing full body
armor
Europe's largest atomic energy plant is
situated perilously close to very active
front lines on the one hand we can see
that
the situation is serious the
consequences are there and they are real
at the same time there are measures that
are
being taken uh
[Music]
to stabilize the situation
it is not the first time fears have been
raised for the safety of the plant under
Russian control since the early stages
of the war this is Weaponry the Russians
say has been fired in the vicinity by
Ukrainian forces in truth Crossfire goes
both ways and accidental or deliberate
damage here could have catastrophic
consequences
Jonah Hall Al Jazeera Kiev